good afternoon it's me again
I'm like a bad penny I keep coming back
if you take your seats again we'd like
to begin our program and it's now my
pleasure to turn the podium over to a
man who makes all this possible of
course and that's the president of
Hillsdale College dr. Larry P Arne
[Applause]
thank you all for coming a lot wow I
should mention the college as well we're
scheduling to have college again next
year we're in that worst time of the
year right now because we're all strung
out and tired and the seniors are
emotional and so whatever they got to
complain about they complain about right
now but in about a week
final papers and exams start coming due
and then it turns into the scene of the
walking dead and they shut up about all
that and then there's a week of joy for
the seniors they get that we're going to
close our construction project over
there the night before commencement and
have the seniors and their parents come
for a prayer service so they don't have
to just suffer the construction project
seniors or Tichy about things like that
I want to mention the remarkable Sally
Clark who's one of my favorites she's
the daughter of Gunnar and Louise and
she's the only one I know who is both a
gemologist and a big-game hunter and I'd
like her to stand up
[Applause]
she was looking at some jewelry about my
wife and she said it wasn't worth much
[Laughter]
Mitch McConnell is a native of Alabama
Georgia and Kentucky
he's the longest-serving member of the
United States Senate from that state he
is the second from his state to lead the
Senate I looked it up I was hoping to
find out that his greatest predecessor
Henry Clay was the man in question but
it seems not somebody rather named alben
Barkley of the Democratic Party and so
that means that Senator McConnell has a
clipped his record being not only leader
but also good at it
he went to University of Louisville
undergraduate into Kentucky law school
he's married to Elaine Chao friend of
mine right now secretary of Department
of Transportation when he was elected in
Kentucky in 1984 he was the first one a
Republican elected to that state since
1968 it was the year that were all
reagan won reelection things were going
happily if year of my political views at
that time he has been the chair of the
National Republican Senatorial Committee
minority and Majority Whip Minority
Leader and now Majority Leader and these
offices make him the longest serving
Republican leader in the history of the
Senate it's actually a remarkable career
I remind you that the Republican Party
began back in the 1850s so that's a long
time and I'll also remind you because
I'm so proud of it many of the steps
that led to its founding happen right
across the way over there in central
hall at Hillsdale College I first
noticed the senator and came to admire
him in his opposition to campaign
finance laws
I'm not sure I think that there should
be no such laws but I think that they
should be treated with extreme care and
the reason is they are controlled on our
influence on elections and elections are
the only way in the American form of
government because we don't hold any of
the government powers in our hands we
the sovereigns we can only pick the
people who do
Madison gressil isn't himself that and
his colleagues that they've invented the
first purely representative government
in history and that means elections
matter and if the government controls
them in any way that's partisan then of
course it threatens to remove itself
from the control of the people which in
my opinion is an abiding danger this way
these days anyway and I perked up and
noticed that Mitch McConnell understood
this and I followed him ever since he's
a tough he he wasn't the best friend of
the Obama administration when it was in
power and he was owned
[Applause]
there's more than one view about this of
course and his view was he is the Senate
he's in charge of the Republicans in the
Senate and they should oppose the things
that they're opposed to and they did he
offered the olive branch all the time
once in awhile was taken but once it a
great while he also seems to understand
the confirmation power of the Senate
another important bulwark of that very
important body yeah has confirmed he's
hit the Senate under his leadership has
confirmed more judges than anybody I
think certainly anybody in modern times
including two members of the Supreme
Court
it was I thought a very gutsy thing not
to place the name of Merrick garland who
was nominated by Obama to the seat
vacated by the death sudden death of
Antonin Scalia but I also noticed that
he had a rationale for it and that is
that's a big choice and there's about to
be an election and we don't know who's
gonna win it but we know that the people
should have a say about this Winston
Churchill I will tell you argued all his
life that a parliament should not do
controversial things in the last two
years of its life those should be
confirmed confined to the first two
years when the people have spoken and
then if they get ready to do
controversial things later they should
have an election and let the people
speak about those things seem to me he
acted in that spirit and courageously
because he's not praised for that
everywhere in the medium I think he's a
skillful man and he's been on the side
of a limited government and I am proud
therefore to introduce to you the leader
of the United States Senate Mitch
McConnell
[Applause]
well thank you so much Larry it's
wonderful to be here I've always wanted
to have a opportunity to come to
Hillsdale and this is my first visit and
I want to congratulate all of you who've
been a part of this remarkable
institution for so very long
the I saw 1844 up there I knew that
before I got here but ironically that
was the same year that Henry Clay made
his last run for president never worked
out for him but the same year at
Hillsdale began and 475 years and
Counting this special place has been a
read out for the values that built and
sustained our country
Hillsdale faculty and alumni are all
over the front lines of public service
helping pass down these principles and
apply them to brand new challenges your
academic excellence your independence
your impact it all bears witness to the
truth that Richard Weaver stated so
famously ideas have consequences and as
a result institutions built on good
ideas can reshape human history for the
better
whether it's 13 plucky colonies on the
edge of a new continent or
liberty-loving Baptists abolitionists
who decided to found a college of course
it also takes outstanding leadership and
I cannot say enough about the
generational leader in academic he's led
Hillsdale from strength to strength so I
want to begin by thanking dr. Lurie Arne
for his enormous contributions to
Hillsdale and to the nation
[Applause]
now I must say it's a little
intimidating to stand at this podium in
this place to reflect on the
Constitution I didn't have the benefit
of a Hillsdale education myself and back
when I was a young Senate staffer for a
Kentucky Republican that no one
remembers named Arlo Cooke
there was no Kirby Center on
Massachusetts Avenue making everyone
smarter so let me confess up front I'm
not going to use the next few minutes to
propound any grand new political
theories I'm not going to do that there
are a lot of people running around in
Iowa New Hampshire doing that
partly because I share the distrust of
sweeping ideological visions that have
United even people on our side
conservative thinkers for centuries
remaking society from whole cloth has
always struck me as above anybody's pay
grade
particularly mine but it's also because
I happen to quite like the
constitutional order that we've already
got work pretty well for a long time
policy matters nominations matter but
more than anything else throughout my
career I've tried to preserve the deeper
inheritance our framers left us in the
Constitution that we have so I'm
grateful for the opportunity to share
some of that work with all of you today
now as you can imagine I'm often asked
what being Senate Majority Leader's like
here's what I've settled on it's a
little bit like being the groundskeeper
at the cemetery
everybody's under you but nobody's
listening so what is it the majority
leader gets to do that no one else gets
to do is to decide what we're gonna do
or what we're not gonna do just set the
agenda and as it happens and Larry
mentioned this the most consequential
decision I've made in my career to date
was something I chose not to do not to
do when Justice Scalia passed away in
2016 in the middle of the presidential
campaign I decided we would not fill
that seat until we had an election and I
think we all know how that worked out as
you may recall this occasion a good bit
of indignation on the political world
but the fact is the separation of powers
gives the Senate a big voice in
confirmations the Constitution says
advise and consent consent means what it
says you don't have to consent and the
Senate even though it cannot initiate
nominations and by the way we get 1,200
of them we do have the opportunity to
refuse consent after that that's where
the instruction manual actually runs out
the Senate defines its own criteria the
institution has taken different
approaches at different times in our
history for much of the 20th century
presidents got pretty wide latitude but
from 1844 to 1853 for example the Senate
rejected 7 of 12 Supreme Court
nominations so that was clearly a period
of senatorial assertiveness history also
told us not since the 1880s had any
president gotten a Supreme Court nominee
confirmed by Senate of the opposite
party in the middle of a press
election-year let me say that again
you'd have to go back to the 1880s to
find the last time a Senate of a
different party than the president
confirmed a Senate nominee by president
of a different party so I thought I was
on pretty sound ground in spite of all
the whining and complaining you heard on
the left about not acting on the garland
the Merrick garland nominations I
figured I was in even better shape and I
were remembered did Joe Biden who was
chairman the Judiciary Committee in 1992
when Bush 41 was reckoning for a second
term even though there was not a vacancy
helpfully opined that if there were he
wouldn't fill it oh no yes I found out
that 18 months before the end of Bush 43
tenure in the White House my counterpart
Chuck Schumer had said if there were
vacancies they wouldn't fill it so I
felt like I was on pretty firm ground
knowing full well that if the shoe had
been on the other foot they would have
done the same thing so I decided to
withhold consent until the American
people weighed in and the results speaks
for itself
Neil Gorsuch the perfect successor to
Justice Scalia whose principal
contribution to judicial history is the
quaint notion that maybe a judge ought
to follow the law as it's written you
wouldn't think that would be
controversial
but it had become that way over the
years so not only did the president send
us a terrific nominee in nil horses most
of you probably know already that most
litigation never makes it to the Supreme
Court and we confirmed 30 Circuit Judge
judges in the first two years of
President Obama that's a record for any
president in the first two years in
history and what do they all have in
common first of all they're young these
are lifetime appointments young men and
women who believe in the quaint notion
that maybe the job the judges to follow
the law Justice Scalia also said you
know you're not a very good judge of
occasionally you're not uncomfortable
with the outcome you reach because it's
not your personal opinion it's what the
law requires
he also helpfully added an admonition I
think makes a lot of sense if you want
to make policy while you run for office
these are the kind of men and women
we've been putting on the Supreme Court
and the circuit courts and we're now at
37 counting the ones we've confirmed
this year to the circuit courts I
personally believe these lifetime
appointments are the single most
important thing we can do for the
long-term future of our country and on
election night but I realized that the
stars are aligned and we had a
Republican president I was hopeful he'd
make these kind of nominations my first
priority immediately was what's the
thing we can do that will have the
longest positive impact on the country I
love the tax bill for example but we
never leave taxes alone an elections
change and new people come in with
different priorities how can you have
the longest impact on the country in a
positive way clearly if you had the
right kind of nominees it was going to
be the courts and we're going to keep on
doing that there'd be no vacancies left
behind at the end of this Congress I can
tell you that
[Applause]
Scalia used to point out that we have a
written constitution you know they don't
in England a written constitution words
in there and so we don't only have a
fuzzy kind of common-law tradition we do
have precedent but we don't rely
entirely on a fuzzy common-law tradition
we have actual written words that are
supposed to mean the same thing no
matter what year it is or what the
readers politics may be I can't stress
this enough this should not be a
partisan position in fact it's revealing
that so many Democrats don't see it that
way
if simply applying the plain meaning of
the Constitution looks like an attack on
your agenda maybe you should revise your
agenda
[Applause]
the American people didn't consent to be
ruled by nine super legislators or nine
freelance moral philosophers the people
did not consent to unelected judges who
start with an outcome in mind and then
torture torture the text until it costs
up a convenient interpretation so the
president and I have prioritized
restoring our third branch of
constitutional government but it's not
been easy you all remember what the
process became after Justice Kennedy's
retirement special interests had pledged
a stop Brett Kavanaugh but he was too
well qualified and too well regarded we
all know what followed by the end we
were not just voting on one man's career
one way or another a bigger statement
was going to be actually made did
partisan politics override the
presumption of innocence we are no
longer entitled to a presumption of
innocence with the judgment of the media
or the mob substitutes for actual
evidence with death threats sway the
Senate their times in Senate history
when the principles at stake transition
the issue transcend the issue it's at
hand and my friends this was one such
moment it was palpable and I could not
be more confident that we set the right
precedent and justice Brett Kavanaugh is
now sitting exactly where he belongs
[Applause]
so look as long as we have a white house
sending up the kinds of judges the
American people deserve we will continue
confirming them with everyone I hope we
step closer to a judiciary our framers
would actually recognize this leads to a
second subject I wanted to discuss and
that's the First Amendment and free
speech in America which is Larry
indicated he and I have a common
background in because the more I thought
about it these last crazy weeks in
Justice Cavanaugh's process really
resembled what we see now in college
campuses except for yours I thought that
get a bigger what we mostly mostly see
is angry mobs seeking to intimidate the
notion that if people filled something
with enough passion these emotions
should make the actual facts irrelevant
and literally efforts to shout down
senators and drowned out remarks
well I focused on political speech for a
long time this is an area I have a lot
of experience in well actually not too
much experience I'm reminded I was
recently speaking in my alma mater and
my host slipped up I've been around for
a while by the way as you all know I'm
in my third decade and the president of
the University and introduced me said I
was elected in 1884
as you can imagine there was a lot of
laughter in the room so when I got up I
said you know the biggest break I had in
my early career was that internship I
had with Henry Clay seriously I see
political speech is the mother of all of
our freedoms the Liberty to exchange
ideas is how self-government can play
out and other important questions can
actually be litigated so I built a
reputation somewhat of a First Amendment
purist I didn't earn many admirers by
filibustering the famous mccain-feingold
legislation with its limits on certain
kinds of political speech after all
nobody else was volunteering to defend
money and politics however sort of the
designated spear catcher I was the
plaintiff in the lawsuit that went all
the way to the Supreme Court but the
reality is simple Washington DC cannot
be in the business of limiting stifling
or micromanaging what conversations
Americans are allowed to have about
Washington DC and that's what it was all
about
[Applause]
of course it costs money to buy airtime
and film commercials it also costs money
to run a magazine or to buy a poster
board for a political rally every act of
expression costs something cracking down
on some speech will just unfairly
privilege other speakers it cannot be
that a successful American gets huge
power to shape the discourse if they use
their money to buy CNN itself but others
prefer to say in other business and they
can't participate what nonsense when you
lay the principles bear
they obviously run contrary to the
Constitution that a certain amount of
speech is excessive who's going to make
that decision that certain speakers are
undesirable who's going to make that
decision that the federal government
should defend us delicate citizens from
speech the bureaucrats deem unhelpful
but the appetite to curtail speech is
insatiable
this year the Speaker of the House is
designated her top priority a sprawling
set of changes to election law and
political speech regulations and
unfortunately every Senate Democrat has
sponsored on a mostly identical bill
among other things it would convert the
Federal Elections Commission designed
after Watergate to be evenly bipartisan
into a partisan body controlled by the
President of whichever party happened to
be in power at the time this is actually
the institution that writes the rules
for political participation that tracks
citizens political speech and
contributions that enforce Washington
speech regulations with penalties
imagine the founders reaction to given a
body these powers and then making it
partisan the same legislation would
force some online platforms to catalogue
every advertisement they sell not just
about campaigns
about issues and perhaps most alarmingly
but also force more nonprofits to
disclose citizens private affiliations
this is a battle I thought we'd already
won by the way
the n-double-a-cp
fought the state of Alabama's effort to
get their membership lists in the 1950s
it went all the way to the Supreme Court
justice Harlan rule that such privacy is
a key piece of First Amendment right to
freely assist associate in other words
the government is not entitled to your
list as a condition to speak we know
exactly what all this new regularly
available information about citizens
beliefs and affiliations would bring
about we've seen online mobs hound
people from their jobs because they
express the wrong views we've seen the
IRS harassed conservative nonprofits on
account of their ideas this is hardly a
climate in which politicians should
forcibly punish more citizens publish
more citizens private information so the
First Amendment needs my friends
constant vigilance for my part I'm
totally committed to fighting these
latest attacks tooth and nail speaker
Pelosi's bill is not going to pass the
United States Senate
[Applause]
but look the vigilant's can't just be
from those of us in government
protecting our speech culture is a
national responsibility for everyone for
all of us I remember when I was in
college there's a while back we had all
kinds of speakers we had great debates
nobody thought it would be clever to
shut down the debate one year we had
senator Barry Goldwater there I was
twenty years old
on the front page of the local paper but
Barry Goldwater but the next year we had
socialist spokesman and perennial
candidate Norman Thomas who would run
for president every year back when
socialism was still a bad word unlike
currently so we had the whole spectrum
and if we'd had trigger warnings back
then believe me there was something to
offend everyone now we have this bizarre
two-step step one is saying you're
personally hurt and offended my goodness
by hearing perspectives you don't agree
with step two is saying those hurt
feelings should outweigh the speaker's
right to be heard and your peers right
to listen to the speaker who are these
delicate children not I'm in school here
and so we see countless examples of deep
platforming and hecklers vetoes it's
really disturbing and the intolerance is
leaking out of our universities and
beginning to infect more of our body
politic so look we all need to fight
back against this toxic counter
constitutional anti speech trend in our
nation's institutions and in each of our
personal lives every American should
discipline ourselves to remember the
difference between simple disagreement
and permanent outrage and avoid being
part of the problem avoid being part of
that problem the latest threat I want to
mention today is slightly different as
you probably heard there have been
enough
how they create a proposal introduced
lately by my colleagues across the aisle
hmm a few weeks ago the Senate remember
I'm the guy gets to decide what we vote
on or don't vote on so a few weeks ago
the Senate vote on the green new deal a
[Applause]
proposal to abolish all energy sources
that middle-class families can actually
afford forcibly remodel every building
in America create government guaranteed
jobs for everyone and make enormous
changes to the fabric of middle-class
life nationwide it wasn't a serious
environmental bill among other things
its proponents opposed nuclear power
even though that would have a big part
of cutting carbon emissions as urgently
as these folks would like and by the way
estimates pegged the cost listen to this
the cost of this thing at more money
than the entire gross domestic product
of the entire world
as of 2017 so it'd be hard to argue my
friend that this is a serious policy
proposal it was more of a manifesto it
was authored and championed by
politicians from New York and Portland
and Cambridge Massachusetts who seem to
be just plain fed up with having to
share a country with people who won't
update their lifestyles industries and
family values to match the latest
coastal fashions they're just outraged
by all of us basically it was an effort
to declare a kind of economic culture
war and yet only for just four of 47
Senate Democrats could drink bring
themselves to oppose it only four of
them
let me say that again 43 of 47 Democrats
including all all of the presidential
candidates couldn't vote no even on this
absurdity and I haven't gotten yet to
medicare-for-all look as a Republican
it'd be easy to laugh all this off just
a left-wing Christmas list frankly
that's a mistake and I told the students
about a few minutes ago
something deeper is going on here
because these sensational policy
proposals are coming hand-in-hand with
an equally radical set of political
proposals that would shred the framers
wisdom and radically change our
government in the past three months
alone progressive leaders have proposed
ending the electoral college
switching to national popular vote
packing the Supreme Court with more
liberal seats packing the Senate through
news statehood for the District of
Columbia abolishing the Senate
filibuster for legislation and that
Democratic friendly overhaul of election
laws i earlier mentioned to add that all
up progressives are openly acknowledging
they'll never get there
through the constitutional machinery as
its operated for centuries
so they've concluded it's the
constitutional machinery that has to go
change the rules if you can't win
otherwise so this isn't an ordinary
policy debate it is as I just said an
effort to change the rules of American
politics itself our whole nation is
founded as a delicate compromise between
different states different regions
competing interests this seeks to blow
all of that up blow it all up look how
the two halves fit perfectly together
policies that would let coastal cities
like New York and San Francisco redesign
the whole country in their image paired
with political changes so that simply
running up the score in those same few
places would give you all the lovers of
power I see this is a total rejection of
the federalism and respect for regional
diversity that gave us the Senate itself
the electoral college the whole founding
compromise of our Constitution in 2008
then-senator Obama
derided certain regions by saying quote
they get bitter they cling to guns or
religion or antipathy to people who
aren't like them in 2016 shortly after
secretary Clinton's lost she bragged
that at least she won quote listen to
this the places that are optimistic
diverse dynamic moving forward well you
can infer what she thinks about farm
country
small towns small cities industrial
areas that President Trump carried you
can guess her views on the places she
called all that red in the middle all
that red in the middle
in other words America's heartland
that would include Hillsdale Michigan
well now this Geographic prejudice has
been weaponized into actual proposals
that dilute the voices of Americans who
aren't enlightened enough to elect
Democrats I happened to be the only one
of the four congressional leaders who
isn't from New York or California and
you better believe that my Republican
colleagues and I are not about to let
the fundamental traditions of our
constitutional order crumble crumble
because of Brooklyn and the bay area are
tired of playing by the rules
[Applause]
there's a famous poem by a nice German
writer who was making fun of the Soviet
commas ours would it not be easier yes
for the government to dissolve the
people and elect another sound familiar
I think this is exactly what our friends
on the Left have in mind our
Constitution and our electorate have
disappointed them have disappointed them
so we the people need to be reformed to
fit their vision this is the Woodrow
Wilson playbook
President Wilson was the quintessential
progressive you were either on board
with his program or you were a pointless
stick in the mud he gave speeches
mocking conservatives as people who
overslept overslept while a happy parade
into the future passed them by
he called constitutional limits a
straitjacket so it's interesting that it
was President Wilson who oversaw new
levels of racial segregation in federal
office it was President Wilson who
premiered the birth of a nation at the
white house the racist movie that
sparked the twentieth century revival of
the Ku Klux Klan so so much for the
genius so much for the genius leading a
parade into the future my favorite
political philosopher apart from the
founders is Edmund Burke Burke would
have hated Wilson believe me he saw
government not as some abstract science
but as a practice that you learned
through experience he thought you fight
to preserve what works you cautiously
reform what doesn't and you lean hard
hard hard on tradition all along the way
he said a statesman job is that wants to
preserve and to reform now that's a
mission statement to preserve and reform
at the same time
Burke goes on to say people will
complain that this process takes too
long
you can't remake everything right away
you take
years and decades to get it right here
was his response without question it
might and it ought to take a while
that's especially true in my institution
the Senate is where America plays the
long game as Majority Leader you know I
can imagine plenty of Republican
policies that I'd love to pass with
fewer than 60 votes if the legislative
filibuster were no more but I also know
exactly what life is like in the
minority I know the litany of harrowing
thinks my side was able to block using
the very same powers when we were in the
minority the Senate was designed to
require genuine consensus before making
policy genuine consensus both sides
should respect that design and continue
to let the Senate legislate like the
Senate and if the boaters the Supreme
Court the Senate and the Constitution
are all stumbling blocks where Democrats
plan to rule over middle America like
we're colonies of the coastal cities
then something needs to change alright
maybe they ought to consider changing
their ideas how about that
maybe they'll learn to compete in red
states how about that so those are the
three constitutional challenges as I see
them restoring the judiciary or we've
made real progress defending free speech
which takes constant vigilance and all
of you should be involved in that and
combatting this effort to wipe away
federalism and empower a particular
faction of our nation to forcibly
redesign the whole thing but I can't
conclude without one more mention of my
hero Henry Clay he said the Constitution
of the United States was made not merely
for the generation that then existed but
for posterity unlimited undefined
endless perpetual posterity
he said that in February of 1850 the
hour was growing dark tensions were
rising
later that year his own compromise of
1850 would help push off the Civil War
for another decade but the writing on
the wall was already coming into focus
yet even in the midst of that turmoil
clay kept his eyes on the North Star and
the North Star was of course the
Constitution he knew it was America's
priceless heirloom our inheritance to
preserve and to reform at the same time
the Constitution is what allows our
fierce debates and disagreements to be
debates among neighbors friends and
fellow citizens because we subscribe to
this structure because we honor the
process because we try to keep ourselves
honest as we keep the other side if
Henry Clay could maintain that
perspective even on the brink of chaos
surely surely my friends we can do it
today surely we can remember that the
soul of our Republic is not each day's
debates or the contents of cable news
it's not even our serious policy
differences is the broader consensus in
which all of this
conflict takes place beneath all else
America is built on good ideas the
Declaration distills them the
Constitution and its limits allow them
to flourish and as long as these things
endure so shall we
so I want to close by thanking you once
more Lauren my deep gratitude dr.
weiland dr. Spaulding for helping confer
the honor I'm receiving today I couldn't
be happier to be here I've always wanted
to be a graduate of Hillsdale so thanks
for all the Hillsdale community for
coming today it's been a joy to be here
I couldn't thank you you know
[Applause]
[Applause]
Winston Churchill loved to say that he
was when he got an honorary degree he
was always better at getting degrees
than he was passing exams not true of
Senator McConnell or for that matter of
Winston Churchill upon the
recommendation of the Faculty of
Hillsdale College and with the authority
of its Board of Trustees I hereby confer
upon senator Mitch McConnell the
honorary degree Doctor of public service
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you for coming to help us pay
respect to the senator and thank you for
being here
[Applause]